that's a turkey Happy Thanksgiving you
guys so as you know the Jurassic world
trailer has dropped and we have a show
called movie fights or we debate about
different topics we'll argue about
movies this debate could not wait there
are some opposing viewpoints on Jurassic
world and we're gonna get into it today
with a supercool panel he is the host of
movie fights the creator of honest
trailers the bearded one Andy signor hey
guys good to have you Andy and he is the
director of screen junkies he edits
honest trailers mr. dan merle i'm ready
to do this so you are flaccid over this
trailer i have some major concerns out
ok gotcha
andy you loved it this movie the
original movie Jurassic Park as a
thirteen-year-old aspiring filmmaker
that didn't even know I wanted me
filmmaker that movie defined me this
take on it to me is the is the finally
deserve at sequel that I feel like we
should have had to me this idea of the
parks active it's in full swing but they
know or make it more exciting and you're
gonna make these new stupid dinosaurs to
try and bring people in and they play
God I think it's gonna be all yeah okay
okay
Andy loves it dan well you know listen I
agree with with everything you just said
Jurassic Park was like a milestone and I
was 10 years old when it came out it was
a milestone and I agree that I like the
concept of the movie but this is the
trailer we're talking about here and I
saw some very troubling red flags for me
okay
give us one red flag and then we'll get
a rebuttal from Andy on it well I mean I
read all the same interviews with Colin
Trevorrow he was talking about it and a
big thing and he was pushing was
practical practical practical okay
there was nothing practical in this
trailer a lot of CGI the gates were CG
the environments were CG the dinosaurs
were CG and I understand that some of
the dinosaurs have always been CG in
Jurassic Park but I think that they
missed out on an opportunity to show us
some physical dinosaurs because here's
the problem with these sequels that have
been that we wait so long for waited a
long time for Indiana Jones for what do
we get CGI crapfest wait a long time for
the Star Wars prequels would we get CGI
crapfest
and when you do a trailer that shows
nothing but CGI for me I start going
Oh it puts it I start putting the
barriers oh well those were those were
just flawed movies it's so silly to me
did you have that problem at dawn of the
plight of the Apes
did you have the problem with guardians
of the galaxy no cuz they are CGI now I
know but are they gonna get real
dinosaurs to jump out of an ocean and
eat a shark that's not do it but James
Gunn didn't say oh I went and shot
guardians of the galaxy in space and
they didn't say oh we trained these real
Apes to be Apes and like they have been
pumping up this return to the practical
effects to the real Jurassic Park and
all I see as a clerk had CGI dinosaurs
right but it wasn't all CGI I'm just
saying that like they have this I think
that they had to overcome where they
they have to sell the fans of this old
movie that this isn't gonna break your
you're so anti the CG was it bad CGI I
mean it would strike me as bad CG for me
it's like if they had these huge awesome
shots I mean the t-rex is cool is the CG
in the first movie was the coolest
dinosaur was that big real like huge
t-rex it looked real and CG can never
look as photo real as something real
does I will give you three parts of that
trailer that blew me away that I was
excited to go one the shark the shark
over the the thing with the SeaWorld
audience going that was that was awesome
that was great yeah that was neat shot
to a park in full capacity there are
people finally in this park how many
times have we watched Rasik park with an
empty friggin theme park we have now
people in peril tons of them and it's
actually more dangerous and more
thrilling to me to actually see
Universal Studios Disney World type
level people in a place where the
dinosaurs are gonna run amuck super svet
the third we haven't even brought sup
Chris Pratt is riding with Raptors that
is awesome
and I'm gonna I don't know I saw some
boiler yeah I'm assuming and I'm taking
judgment in my own what I think means I
think he's training those velociraptors
and I think the velociraptors are gonna
be the good guys and I think that's
gonna be so cool
if the velociraptors are teamed up with
Chris Pratt to take down the hybrid
dinos
that's gonna be so sick well I just hope
Chris Pratt riding with dinos is better
than Shia LaBeouf swinging with monkey
it will be okay I'm holding you to that
you mentioned how exciting it was that
they're in a theme park that's working
you know what else was working
velociraptors
the scariest thing in the world like Ida
wow they're domesticated part to that
scene when they're in the field with the
fallout surges and the tails are coming
up in the guys they just get yanked down
you don't oh my god that was one of the
scariest scenes in the whole franchise
for me but this again like I said I'm
not saying this is gonna be a bad movie
but this trailer put up some red flags
they're like new dinosaurs oh we made
hybrid dinosaurs that's not just a cool
element for the movie it takes us to
this philosophical level of man just
trying to control nature a formula that
works is with it you tried to mess with
it in the sequels and it didn't work and
you finally can go back to that original
formula and make it work again and you
love let's change this let's do this oh
whoa whoa whoa they didn't mess with the
formulas the other trees are exactly the
same movie that's the problem with them
they come into the abandoned park all
the dinosaurs are loose it's so they
became so boring what was great about
this one is it's now active it's they
have time has passed they've perfected
it and now let's give the hybrid
dinosaurs what's so beautiful to me is
like if SeaWorld can make hybrid sharks
they'd make a million Irish arks they'd
make an octopus shark if they could
because whatever they could do to bring
in visitors they do it's not called an
octopus shark shark it's called
Sharktopus sure I'm with you yeah that
you leave a point for that if they can
make the Sharktopus with tentacles yes
course we'd all go line up and see it
it's true I think we learned from
blackfish that SeaWorld is soulless but
it's nice um that I think everyone's
soulless and they all want to see the
next crazy thing and I think that was
realists it's true Dino I agree I will I
love I don't like that it's a high but
to me the hybrid I know is the villain
you're gonna go against the hybrid I
know that's what I I think it's not like
we're like oh cool let's see which new
hybrid dinos in the movie that's the
whole point of the plot is like screw
the hybrid Dino I want the old-school
dinos and that's what should have stuck
here I just think we're coming at it
from two different ways like you're the
dreamer of dreams you're the guy that's
like doesn't this concept sound cool
does it oh I want to see this I want to
see this this sounds cool and for me I'm
just so III and II I sit and honest
trailers for three weeks a day or three
days a week I see what becomes of some
of these movies I do looking at it and
I'm seeing in this trailer I'm seeing
the seeds of these things that we've
ripped apart in the past I'm seeing over
reliance on see a guy I'm seeing messin
with
tried-and-true formula your fee I
totally unfounded about what they showed
of Chris Pratt and the trailer so you
just want the same plot of the first
movie but with a packed road theme park
and that's different enough for you yeah
cuz that first it was one of the best
movies of all time let's see I don't
agree with that I think we don't want to
just assume it again that's yeah if you
just keep it again that that's how you
get like movies like hangover was good
but then hangover to try to do the exact
same thing aside from the park um that
this twist idea of potentially some of
these dinos have been trained like
SeaWorld style and can be used to help
us really cool twist and adds a new
layer to it let me ask you this why did
they not show a t-rex in this trailer
the t-rex is the franchise and that
really would have turned me around and
not seeing the t-rex there it kind of
adds to my fears of maybe there's gonna
be a boss fight of t-rex against that
new way be and maybe so but I just I
don't want my heart broken how I don't
want Jurassic Park to break my heart no
at this point movies will break your
heart
Oh perfect and over I will say I feel
like as if we're doing trailer fights it
got me pumped I'm excited but really all
the trailer did to me was reaffirm a lot
of the stuff that's leaked about the
movie and I felt like we were just doing
service of okay we know you a lot of you
already knew this happened here are the
shots that sort of confirm this is
what's happening yeah I do think they
could have done a cooler play to the old
movie like they teased it with the water
and the Fartman they needed some little
little nuance reference I think even
more specifically to the original movie
to get you a little bit more nostalgic
about yeah I will say for in the defense
of the trailer wasn't amazing he could
have done that but I'm so jazzed in the
concept of movie and all the visuals
confirmed the the plot that I have
senses it's a Megalodon fish coming up
into water to get that shark renew all
right I'm gonna bottom-line it right now
are you gonna see it hell yeah are you
gonna see it oh yeah yeah I'm gonna see
it - we're all gonna see it what did you
think of the trailer let us know in the
comments section below
coolest answer we're gonna send you
screen junkies t-shirt I'm al Rudnick
this is Andy signor Dan Merle check out
movie fights where no guys wait is fight
about hell yeah man that was fun but I
really miss her Thanksgiving
addition of reading our hateful comments
we've had so many Rudy Vasquez says your
arms are hairy as last Thanksgiving I
said your arms were hairiest I still
stand by my word if the only the real
Rudy Vasquez was here today I am what
yeah Rudy Vasquez Rudy vaska's himself
you are in fact the real Rudy basket
yeah I think so Rudy now I want you to
really prove it
the arms are various boom there it is
there it is
you know get the [ __ ] out of here come
here I'm just kidding we love you Rudy
we love our haters I want to thank you
for watching the show
Rudy thank you for being there you for
having me have a happy Thanksgiving hit
me up on Twitter I'm Hal Rudnick I'm
Rudy Vasquez bye-bye bye-bye
so we are going to shoot an episode of
screen junkies right here with you as
our star guest